[Music]
producer showed me this picture this was
taken at your house tell us what's going
on here that appears to be taken from
the inside we have an infestation
apparently yeah if my wife's birthday I
got her an elephant in the backyard I
rented and this is it's not funny see
this is supposed to be very funny and if
you ask my wife it wasn't funny I
thought it would be cool to rent an
elephant for her birthday and I said
honey come out in the backyard look what
I got you and I got her an elephant with
for the day but I didn't get her there
was no lunch served there was nothing
there was no I didn't I didn't invite
anybody was just my wife in the backyard
after an hour she's going so what do we
do and then the elephant it's you know
it's an a wild animal it's started
pulling out a lot a lot of our trees it
poked it's not funny and pulled out our
trees and they said it was hot it need
the hoe so we hosed it and then it sunk
into the it broke all our sprinklers and
then it defecated so we still have a bit
of pile and holes and trees were gone
there was no birthday cake or any why
don't you think this was a good idea
well now I don't I learned you learn
from your mistakes with a girl that had
everything I mean I thought it would be
cool to have a it's not cool don't ever
rent an elephant and leave it in you and
I've been with this woman forever I've
been with this woman that like through
the bush years now she waxes but I mean
the thing is that
[Applause]
a long long time I'm telling the early
seventies there was a 70s